they're into garden here's better Smith  jr. driving his first bucket after dick  that's what he does roads it thrives  that time underneath off the glass on  the sidelines but this is Smith jr.  penetrating creating off the glass line  looking for his first port Jack should  committed the personal now we mentioned  his field goal shooting but his  free-throw percentage has been  well-documented as well his free-throw  field goal is the best of all time his  free-throws almost the worst of all time  although this season he said a  career-high 68 percent from the line  which stood in the light of the crowd  making at first we see hundreds and  applause majority champs users with the  Clippers regain this fame  [Music]  [Applause]